[Music]
Joker it's the moment you've been
waiting for so many legendary fighters
are you sure you can handle this I mean
he's got a knife and a gun I'm sure
he'll be fine
I don't know it looked pretty tough
harness the power of the heart to summon
a persona unleash the rebellious spirit
brawling inside you persona
[Music]
Oh our sin our sin you to use a more
powerful persona what are you talking
about awesome
it's Jupiter's main persona as long as
you hold on to your rebellious spirit
our sin we give your attacks an extra
punch you can use wings instead of his
grappling hook
if Joker is attacked while our sin is
around he can counter-attack
this is mementos the palace birds in the
hearts of the masses right yes and
mementos have a great isn't its entire
existence is secret the base color
changes depending on the
[Music]
now's a chance let's help them out
[Music]
smashes looking cool a joker
[Music]
the version 3.0 update for the Super
Smash Brothers ultimate game it's almost
here what are we adding you ask you're
about to find out but first
[Music]
as part of the fighters past Challenger
pack one introduces Joker from persona 5
with his cunning moves and knack for
knives opponents will fall victim to
Joker's masterful manipulation for his
neutral special he wields a gun to shoot
continuously press and hold the button
will repeatedly tap it while shooting
you can also dodge forward backward or
in midair his up special fires a
grappling hook it can be aimed at a
diagonal angle or you can use it to pull
opponents closer and latch onto edges
his side special invokes a hot with a
mere finger snap the initial hit isn't
very strong but it does inflict
additional damage over time and know
this these are not even their final
forms the full power of these special
moves must be unleashed the trick his
down special rebels guard Joker's
rebellion gauge fills up slowly over
time when he gets hit by an opponent or
when he's behind in terms of damage or
stock
[Music]
and by using rebels gars he can fill the
gauge faster while reducing any damage
received by half if you press and hold
the button after the move is activated
you can even defend from combo attacks
when you release the button the opponent
will get knocked back once it's
rebellion gauge is full
he'll unmask and summon a manifestation
of his persona our sin until the gauge
runs out our sin will assist Joker in a
powerful way
return
with his persona at his side Joker can
deal additional damage in each attack
and beyond that especially would change
his neutral special upgrades to gun
special it handles the same as before
only now he'll fire three bone per shot
it's up special transforms into wings of
rebellion using our sends wings you'll
swiftly rise up while this move won't
deal damage it will make you invincible
for time so have a safe flight for his
side special our sin invokes a gown
this large blasts repeatedly hits
opponents inflicting them with
longer-lasting and additional damage his
down special performs one of two counter
attacks each triggering automatically
for melee attacks you'll counter with
Texan cars and projectiles can be
deflected with Makara times oh by the
way our sin is completely invincible and
then there's Joker's file smash all-out
attack after cutting through foes don't
want to coordinated strikes with the
Phantom peeves of Hearts in case the
first slice didn't cut it you can try
again once more by tilting the control
stick back in the other direction our
sin doesn't change Joker's final smash
so feel free to use it whenever you want
[Music]
Joker's victory screen replicates the
one in persona 5 the phantom thieves
have something to say about his
victories too when Joker taunts Morgana
shows up his alternate costume is its
shootin academy uniform good thing he
can use his glasses to summon our sin
[Music]
we're also adding in the new stage
mementos in this mysterious underground
many twists and turns will come your way
during battle
and before long the Phantom thieves of
hearts will rush to the scene in the
Morgana car
[Applause]
[Music]
if you count the arrangements 11 music
tracks will be added in there not only
from persona 5 but also from persona 4
in persona 3 when one of these tracks
from persona 3 or persona 4 plays at
mementos the color of the stage and
background will change set your
preferred playback ratio in my music the
victory screen changes in the same way
when Joker wins Challenger pack 1 will
include the new fighter Joker his stage
mementos and the persona music tracks
when it launches on April 17th
[Music]
if you purchase this pack you'll also
get a joke around in classic mode and
open up a special version of the spirit
board you can also purchase the Super
Smash Brothers Ultimate Fighter pass for
access to this challenger package and
all others for a total of five packs
we're currently hard at work on the
other fighters keep an eye out for news
about them in the future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the nume fighter costumes will be
available for purchase April 17 with
more to come in the future
[Music]
finally let's cover the new content
included in the free version 3.0 update
[Applause]
make your own stages and try them out
immediately with the new stage builder
in handheld mode you can freely draw
using the touchscreen
[Music]
create moving platforms spinning
platforms whatever strikes you
there are even new stage elements to
choose from
[Music]
and their front and back layers by
changing layers you can add decorative
elements to your stages
[Music]
when you finish a stage you can battle
there by selecting it from this tab on
the stage select screen now you can
import videos saved to your Nintendo
switch system to a timeline and splice
them together editing is very simple
just pick the parts you want to keep add
some background music and subtitles and
choose how to transition from scene to
scene once your video is complete simply
export
you could keep it all to yourself
but creations are meant to be shared
aren't they you can view gameplay videos
and State is created and uploaded by
users around the world
beyond viewing players videos and
replays you can also upload and download
new fighters in stages
[Music]
if you find something you like give it a
yeah or you can even follow the person
who posted it
[Music]
servus found in the Nintendo switch
online app for smart devices
the app already supports voice chat and
now you'll be able to easily view
recommended videos and stages in smash
world without starting up the game
[Music]
you can also search for videos by
fighter recommended stages can be viewed
in one place if you find some you like
simply tap the queued downloads button
[Music]
the next time you start up Super Smash
Brothers ultimate you'll be able to
download them to your system
[Music]
you can also check ingame notifications
here or create a new spirit team by
using spirits in your collection the
version 3.0 update of Super Smash
Brothers ultimate will be released on
April 17
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you